ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงกรมไม่ได้
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนหรอนักเรียนวันนี้
ก็
อยู่กับเราคลาสสิกอินเนอร์นะคะไปแล้วเนาะ
ก็เจอกับคริงแล้วก็ใครคะ
ครูฟ้าค่ะอยู่ฝั่งไหน
รูขวาคะก็วันนี้ใช่ไหมวันนี้ฉันว่านัก
เรียนน่าจะจำได้แล้ววันนี้เนี่ยเราสองคน
ก็จะมาเล่นเกมงูเกมอะไรคะผู้หญิงก็จะเป็น
เกมเกี่ยวกับผลไม้ผลไม้ผู้หญิงหายไปไหน
เนี่ย
x เกี่ยวกับเอ่อและ
ผลไม้ใช่ไหมสับปะรดทุเรียนวังคุดแอปเปิ้ล
กล้วยองุ่นไหมคะทั้งหมดนี้เนี่ยเป็นผลไม้
หน้าแล้วเล่นยังไงอ่ะเกมเวลาเล่นก็คือครู
หญิงแล้วนะคะก็จะมีรูปไหมในนี้เนี่ยจริงๆ
เวลาเปิดเปิดขึ้นมามีแต่ผัวจะเปิดขึ้นมา
ก็จะเป็นผลไม้แต่ครูฟ้าจะไม่รู้ไม่เห็น
ไม่เห็นน้าถึงรู้แล้ว
ก็คือกูฟ้าจะต้องคิดใช่ไหมชายครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่รู้แล้วว่าในเนี้ยเป็นผลไม้อะไรถ้าครู
ฟ้านะเนี่ยอยากรู้ใช่ไหมผลไม้
ทำอะไรครูฟ้าก็ต้องมีคำถามที่คำถาม
สายฟ้าต้องถามคำถามครูหญิงน่ะให้ถามได้ 1
2  3  3 คำถามอะไรก็ได้อะไรก็ได้ใช่ไหม
ต๊ายตายพร้อมไอ้ฮักดูฟ้า
พร้อมค่ะมีตัวอย่างน้องไม่เอาอ่ะ
นี่ค่ะผู้หญิงนะมีรูปแล้วเนาะมี 2 ใบ
คำถามที่ 1 ครูฟ้าจะถามอะไรคะ
ผลไม้อันนี้มีสีอะไรหนอผลไม้อันนี้หรอ
สีเหลืองค่ะ
สีเหลือง
มีสีเหลือง
คำถามที่ 2
ผลไม้อันนี้
รูปทรงเป็นยังไงโหเวลาเห็นใช่ไหมเวลาดูก็
จะเป็น
วงรีค่ะครูฟ้าวงรี
ผลไม้นี้เนี่ยสีเหลืองแล้วก็รูปทรงเป็นวง
รี
ๆที่ 3 ถามอะไรคำถามที่ 3 ผลไม้อันนี้ลูก
เล็กหรือลูกใหญ่มึงเล็กหรือใหญ่
ใจนะอ่า
ผู้
ใหญ่
โครงฟ้ารู้หรือยังคะผลไม้อันนี้คืออะไร
ให้คิดว่า
คิดว่า
สับปะรดค่ะ
สับปะรดสับปะรดรถถูกต้อง
อ้า
สับปะรดหายเวลาดู
สีเหลืองแสงรูปทรงเป็นวงริใหญ่ลูกใหญ่ก็
เป็นสับปะรดเก่งมาก
ดีใจ
โอเค
ต่อไป
มาแล้ว
ผลไม้ลูกนี้น่ะสีอะไรคะมี
สีเขียวค่ะสีเขียว
สีเขียวเขียว
คำถามที่ 2 ถามอะไรคะ
ผลไม้ลูกนี้รูปทรงเป็นยังไง
รูปทรงเป็นวงกลม
วงกลุ่มวง
กลม
คำถามที่ 3 ถามอะไรคะ
ผลไม้ลูกนี้ลูกเล็กหรือลูกใหญ่
ลูก
ไก่
โอ๊ยลูกใหญ่ครูฟ้าผลไม้นี้เนี่ยสีเขียว
รูปทรงเป็นวงกลมก็ลูกใหญ่
มีอะไรคะสีฟ้ารู้ไหมลูกค้าชิดว่า
เป็นแต่งโมค่ะ
ทำไมกูฟ้องตกถูกอยู่แล้ว
โดนเนี่ยสีเขียวเนาะข้างนอกนะฮะอ่า
แล้วก็เป็นวงกลมรูปใหญ่เก่งมากต่อไปต้อง
ให้กูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่รู้
อะไรได้
ผลไม้ต่อไปคืออะไรหน้าผลไม้
เห็นอย่างยังไม่รู้ยังไม่รู้โอเคโอเคอ่ะ
ผลไม้ต่อไปค่ะคำถามที่ 1 ครูฟ้าจะถามอะไร
คะ
ผลไม้ลูกนี้สีอะไรคะ
สีเหลืองก็
ก็มี
สีเขียวเกาะหลีมีทั้งสีเหลือง
แล้วก็สีเขียว
หื่นคำถาม
ผลไม้รูปนี้รูปทรงเป็นไง
ทรงเรียไม่ใช่วงกลม
เป็น
วงรีลิเวอร์รีนะวงรี
ต้องถาม
ที่ 3 ผลไม้ลูกนี้ลูกเล็กหรือว่าใหญ่
ไม่เล็กไม่ใหญ่
กลางๆ
หนูฟ้ารู้ไหมอะไรอ่ะมีรูปฟ้าคิดว่า
มะม่วง
[เพลง]
ไม่รู้ใช่แล้วค่ะมันคือมะม่วง
พรุ่งนี้เนาะตีเขียวแล้วก็สีเหลืองเนาะหา
สีเขียวเนี่ยเป็นมะม่วงดิบใช่ไหมสีเหลือง
มะม่วงสุกมันว่า
ต่อไปครูฟ้าจะเก่งเกินไปแล้ว
ผลไม้ต่อไปค่ะคุณป๊า
ละม้ายไปคะ
คำถามที่ 1
ผลไม้รูปนี้มีสีอะไรคะ
เสคเขียวค่ะสีเขียว
เขียว
คำถามที่ 2
ผลไม้ลูกนี้รูปทรงเป็นยังไงมีรูปทรง
เป็น
วงรีวงรีและวงกลมวงรีก็มีวงกลมก็มีแต่ว่า
ให้มันกลมวงกลม
ผลไม้ลูกนี้ลูกเล็กหรือว่าลูกใหญ่
เล็กลูกอยากใช่ค่ะอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ตัว
อะไรอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ามันคือผลไม้อะไหล่
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ทุเรียนค่ะ
ฟ้ารู้ได้ยังไงถูกต้องค่ะเอาทุกวันคือ
ทุเรียน
[เพลง]
หูฟังเก่งมากผลไม้เนี่ยเก่งมากจะพบภาพ
ต่อไปค่ะสู่ป่าป๊าผลไม้ต่อไป
ผลไม้ลูกนี้สีอะไรคะ
แต่สี
สีแดงค่ะสีแดงอะนี้สีแดงนะสีแดง
คำถามที่ 2 ผลไม้รูปนี้มีรูปทรงเป็นยังไง
ทรงเป็นวงรีค่ะวงรี
วงรี
ผลไม้ลูกนี้ลูกเล็กหรือว่าลูกใหญ่ค่ะ
กลางกลางนะไม่เล็กไม่ใหญ่
[เพลง]
อ้ะอีกหนึ่งครั้งนะว่าครูบาอาจารย์ที่ไม่
ได้สีแดงสวยสีแดง
เม็ดส่งเนี้ยเป็นวงรีวงรียี่
ลูกแหละกลางๆไม่แล้วแล้วก็ไม่ใหญ่
กลางๆรู้รึยังรู้หรือยังอะไร
อะไรอ่ะกูคิดว่าอะไร
ซีรีส์สิแดง
คิดว่า
ชมพู่
ชมพู่ชมพู่ชมพู่ชมพู่ชมพู่
ไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ส่งพู่
ชมพู่ลูกเล็ก
กลางๆไม่เละเราก็ไม่ใหญ่โครงฟ้ารู้ไหมคิด
ออกไหมคะ
คิดว่าแก้วมังกร
แก้วมังกร
ใช่ค่ะ
แก้วมังกรเย้
แต่แก้วมังกรกับชมพู่เหมือนกันใช่ไหมครู
ฟ้าสีแดงเนาะสีแดงสีแดงเหมือนกันหรอเก่ง
ว่าเก่งว่ะและ
ผลไม้ต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าผลไม้ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิง
มาแล้ว
ผลไม้ลูกที่เนี่ย
สีอะไรคะ
ตี๋
เสนเหลืองค่ะสีเหลือง
ผลไม้ลูกนี้รูปทรงเป็นยังไงคะรูปทรงเนี่ย
เป็นวงรีแต่ว่าเป็นวงรีแบบ
พูดชมผู้ส่งจะรู้ไหมเนี่ยยาวๆวงรียาวๆ
ผลไม้ลูกนี้ลูกเล็กหรือว่าลูกใหญ่
ลูกเล็ก
ผลไม้ผลไม้สอันนี้ก็มี
ลูกใช่
ก็มีมีเล็กแล้วก็มีใหญ่มี 2 ใบหัดเลยนะมี
2 แบบใหญ่
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ามันคือผลไม้อะไร
ครูฟาคิดว่ามันคือกล้วยค่ะกล้วยนะกล้วย
กล้วยเหรอกล้วย
กล้วยเตี๋ยวครูฟ้าคิดว่ากล้วยหรอว่าคิด
ว่ามันคือกล้วยกล้วย
ใช่แล้วค่ะ
[เพลง]
เก่งมากเลยกล้วยเน็ตใหญ่ก็มีเล็กก็มี
ชื่อ
เอาอีกหนึ่งชนิดเนาะผลไม้ผลไม้ผลไม้
คำถามที่ 1 ค่ะครูฟ้าอ่ะตอบคำถามพี่หนึ่ง
ถามว่าผลไม้ลูกนี้มีสีอะไร
มีมี
สีแดง
เราก็สีเขียวแดงเขียวเดี๋ยวอ่อน
ผลไม้ลูกนี้มีรูปทรงเป็นยังไงคะ
ส่งเนี้ยเป็นวงรีค่ะ
วงรีวงรี
ผลไม้ลูกนี้ลูกเล็กหรือว่าลูกใหญ่ลูกเล็ก
ลูกเล็ก
ลูกเล็กใช่มีสี 2 สีใช่ไหมมีสีแดงสีเขียว
เป็นวงรีนะรูปทรงเป็นซีรีส์แล้วก็ลูกเละ
องุ่น
คนที่องุ่นใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าคิดว่าองุ่นเหอะ
เก่งจริงว่า
เอ่ออันอื่นหรอเจาะวันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็
ชายผลไม้ใช่มั้ยก็มีอะไรบ้างคะผู้หญิงนี่
สับปะรดเนาะสับปะรด
แตงโม้โม้
มะม่วงมะม่วง
ทุเรียนทุเรียน
ตาย
แก้วมังกรแก้วมังกร
กล้วยกล้วย
ที่ 9 ก็
องุ่นองุ่นสวยไหมคะอย่างองุ่นองุ่นเนี่ย
มีสีอะไรนะพรุนฟ้าสีแดงกับสีเขียวม้าสี
แดงแล้วก็สีเขียวหรือว่าอะไรคะองุ่นสี
ม่วงไหมเออ
อาจจะมีองุ่นสีม่วง
แวะองุ่นเนาะสีม่วง
สีแดง
สีเขียวสวยอรุณแล้วถ้าเป็นกล้วยเหรอคะ
กล้วยเวลาดูสีอะไรสีเหลืองอ่ะสีเหลืองกับ
สีเหลืองนี่ก็สีเหลือง
แล้วถ้าเป็นแก้วมังกรล่ะคะแก้วมังกร
มีสีอะไร
สีแดงสีแดง
แล้วถ้าเป็นทุเรียนทุเรียนทุเรียนนเวลาดู
สีสีอะไรคะ
ทุเรียนเนี่ยสีเขียวค่ะนะสีเขียวสีเขียว
แล้วก็ถ้าเป็นมะม่วงล่ะคะมะม่วงสีเหลือง
กับสีเขียว
สีเหลือง
แล้วก็สีเขียว
ถ้าเป็นแตงโมล่ะคะแตงโมแตงโมสีสีเขียวค่ะ
รักสีเขียวสีเขียว
แล้วก็สับปะรด
สับปะรดสีเหลืองหรอสีเหลืองแปลว่าผลไม้
ดอกไม้วันนี้ที่เราเอามาของส่วนใหญ่ก็จะ
มีสีแดงใช่ไหมคะสีเขียวมันมีสีเขียวแล้ว
ก็สีเหลือง
ชายเนาะวันนี้ก็นักเรียนก็ไม่รู้ผลไม้ใช่
นะจ่ายแล้วก็มีเล่นเกมก็ไม่รู้ว่านัก
เรียนเนี่ยฟังแล้วนักเรียนทายถูกเหมือน
ครูฟ้าเปล่าเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยถูกสมัย
ถูกถูกถูกถูกถูกๆเก่งว่า
นักเรียนก็ลองคิดดูนะหาว่านักเรียนรู้ไหม
คนละม้ายลูกนี้คืออะไรสาวกับที่เราเล่น
เกมเนาะเพราะว่าเราเล่นไปก็มีอรุณ index
รอบ
อะไรครับฟ้าดับมี
กล้วย
แก้วมังกร
ทุเรียน
มะม่วง
แตงโมค่ะเราก็เป็นผลไม้ไทยวันนี้เรามาให้
นักเรียนได้ดูกันนะคะก็วันนี้เราสองคนก็
ต้องไปก่อนใช่ไหมคะก่อนไปนักเรียนอย่าลืม
ทำอะไรคะอันนี้อย่าลืมกด like กด Share
กด Subscribe ได้หานักเรียนแล้วแล้วฉัน
เข้ากันใหม่นะวีดีโอหน้าน้องอีกบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ